thanks to his starring role in two
suicide squad movies captain boomerang
is a household name among countless
comic fans
but how did this dc baddie go from
obscure rogue to one of the most
recognizable anti-heroes in the dc
universe
this is the story of captain boomerang
so who is captain boomerang the short
answer is that he's george digger
harkness
a shameless crook who will do just about
anything to make a buck
he doesn't boast any supernatural
abilities instead carrying an arsenal of
boomerangs that he wheels with lethal
skill
but boomer's weapons aren't just one of
the mill boomerangs with many of them
serving specific purposes
in combat while he acts as kind of a
lone wolf in his earliest appearances
boomerang quickly becomes more of a team
player
even though he's never very good at
getting along with whatever team he's in
he's joined forces with other prominent
villains of the fictional central city
over the years
and more famously is one of the villains
often pressed into service for the
united states government by the
tyrannical amanda waller
digger harkness isn't the most patient
of men either he has a short temper and
can turn on his allies with little
provocation
sadly he's also demonstrated some deeply
problematic beliefs during his many
comic book appearances
particularly in the early suicide squad
comics captain boomerang regularly makes
racist and sexist comments
about his teammates a native australian
digger sees himself as a patriot to his
homeland
though it was later revealed that
because of his criminal exploits
most of his countrymen are actually
ashamed of him
captain boomerang first locks horns with
central city's guardian speedster
the flash in 1960s to flash number 117
while the rogue's blue white and black
costume wouldn't change much between his
debut and his more prominent appearances
in the 80s
the character has changed in other ways
in flash number 117
digger harkness gets the idea to become
captain boomerang after the wwe wiggins
game company
starts searching for a mascot who can
promote their toy boomerangs harkness is
already a thief at that point and he
uses his unique boomerang talents to
help him in his battles with the scarlet
speedster
he's initially able to defeat flash with
one of his lightning boomerangs
and then ties the unconscious flash to a
giant boomerang and shoots
it into the ocean obviously flash
escapes and puts an end to the crooks
plants
in these early appearances captain
boomerang is just as goofy as he is
later on
curiously enough however it's never
specified in this era
that digger harkness is from australia
the country isn't mentioned at all
and his dialogue isn't written to
reflect his nationality
what do you do once you've created
enough villains designed to bring down a
superhero you throw them all together in
a team of course
flash's villainous team up is known as
the rogues who have since gone on to
become one of the most enduring groups
of villains in the history of dc comics
captain boomerang is one of the founding
members of the rogues
he's there in 1962's to flash number 130
to join forces with contemporaries like
trickster
captain cold the top and mirror master
all set against their common enemy
over the years more villains would join
and just about any villain who spent
enough time taking their lumps fighting
the flash
found their way onto the team in some
cases the robes have stepped into more
heroic territory too
every now and then the group stands
against other villains whose actions
against central city jump across the
kind of moral lines that even the rogues
won't cross
while captain boomerang is one of the
first bad guys to count himself among
the rogues eventually he becomes less
and less associated with the group
as his destiny brings him to a very
different team of villains
nowadays captain boomerang is most
famous as a regular fixture in the
modern lineup of task force x
also known as a suicide squad he's a
group member in the very first battle
against brimstone in 1987's legends
number three
and appears regularly in many of the
subsequent volumes of suicide squad
he's also on the team in the justice
league unlimited episode task force x
as well as in 2014's batman assault on
arkham
2018 suicide squad hell to pay and
2020's justice league dark apocalypse
war
you'll also be a member of the group in
the upcoming video game suicide squad
kill the justice league
featured on the team in cw's arrowverse
and of course was played by jai courtney
in 2016 suicide squad and its 2021
follow-up
it's fire
ironically in spite of how often he
works with task force x
captain boomerang is one of the most
disliked members of the team
he also makes sure to be a constant
thorn in the side of the squad liaison
amanda waller who frequently refers to
him as
boomer butt it's surprising how often
captain boomerang finds himself
working for walla considering what a
pain he can be to everyone involved
on the one hand you could say it's a
testimony to his effectiveness in battle
that his presence continues to be
tolerated
there does however appear to be a very
fine line between the two
if you had to be in a suicide squad
captain boomerang is just about the last
guy you'd want to team up with
while the character's portrayal often
changes depending on who's writing him
one thing that tends to remain
consistent is that he has no problem
backstabbing his teammates
in fact captain boomerang betrays one of
his colleagues in one of the team's
earliest adventures
in 1987 suicide squad number one tired
of listening to boomer among the other
team members
mind buggler uses her powers to reveal
his biggest fears
in the following issue captain boomerang
sees that mind boggler is about to be
gunned down from behind by the villain
rustam
he whips out a boomerang to intervene
but stops himself
remembering how mind boggler humiliated
him he then escapes as rustom shoots and
kills mind boggler
in 1988 suicide squad number nine digger
betrays a team mate by using him as
something of a test subject
he isn't sure his superiors mean it when
they threaten to detonate the explosives
strapped to the squad member's arms
so he convinced his slipknots that
they're bluffing after a heated battle
slipknot tries to escape the squad
and he pays for the mistake dearly
captain boomerang's treachery isn't
limited to his early appearances with
the squad either
in 2017 suicide squad number 13 captain
boomerang kills fellow teammate hack
by stabbing her with one of his
boomerangs so yeah not the nicest guy in
the world
despite being a pretty unpleasant
character in general captain boomerang
is actually behind one of the funniest
and longest running subplots in the
history of the suicide squad comics
in 1988 suicide squad number 21 amanda
waller is walking around bel reeve
prison
and considering her recent challenges
when a whipped cream pie flies into her
face
suspecting boomer is the culprit right
away walla summons him
on his way to see her however a pie gets
him too it would take years for the pie
thrower to be revealed
the next victim is nemesis and suicide
squad number 23
then in 1989 suicide squad number 26
vixen gets a pie in the face while
getting frisky with bronze tiger
and bronze tiger gets one a moment later
daily planet reporter lois lane takes
the dessert to the nose and suicide
squad number 30 and julie and dr light
fall victim to this creamy bandit
in the following issue the final pie
victim is major victory in 1990 suicide
squad number 37
captain boomerang tries to frame fellow
squad member punch by filling his locker
with pisces
but he's found out regardless it's
discovered that boomer used his
boomerang tank to get himself in the
face
throwing suspicion off himself early on
in the saga boomer then quits the squad
laughing in walla's face but there's
nothing she can do to punish him so
walla does what any sensible person
would do when they can't extract revenge
for catching a pie to the face
she has him abducted and stranded on a
desert island
in 2004 dc comics released the
game-changing mini-series identity
crisis
the story unfolds with the violent death
of sue dibny
wife to superhero ralph dimny aka the
elongated man
what follows is a mystery that explodes
into many different threads
including a series of shocking reveals
involving misdeeds committed by dc's
heroes
one such threat includes digger harkness
accepting a high profile job that
eventually leads to his death
identity crisis finds captain boomerang
having fallen on hard times
he can hardly rub two pennies together
and among dc's community of super
villains
he doesn't command the respect he once
did in identity crisis number five
boomer embarks on what proves to be his
last job the assassination of jack drake
while he doesn't have any superpowers or
fancy gadgets jack drake is no standard
mark as he's the father of tim drake
the robin of the time terrified that his
sidekick will have to experience what
he's suffered when his own parents were
killed
batman rushes to jack drake's home once
he learns of the plot
but he's too late drake mortally wounds
boomer with a handgun but not before one
of the villains boomerangs likewise
kills drake
aside from a brief stint as a zombie
captain boomerang wouldn't return fully
to life until 2010's brightest day
storyline just before the rebooting of
the dc universe as part of the new 52
event
after this digger hagness is recruited
to join amanda wallace new and improved
suicide squad
a couple of years before the first
suicide squad film was released captain
boomerang made his live-action debut in
season 3 of the cw's arrow
sorry to do this to you but you have
something i
need he shows up in the final moments of
drawback your bow and then gets a lot
more screen time in the brave and the
bold
in arrow digger is a former suicide
squad agent whose last mission didn't go
as planned
once things went sideways lila michaels
opted to activate the bombs and planted
an old task force x recruits next
but apparently the device and digger
malfunctioned the brave and the bold is
one of the earliest team ups between
oliver queen and the flash
and it's clear team arrow could use the
backup digger proves to be just as
formidable an enemy as his comic book
counterpart
though eventually queen and the flash
take him down captain boomerang appears
one more time in season 5 when queen
releases digger and deathstroke from
their island prisons to help him defeat
prometheus
proving just as treacherous as his comic
book counterpart
digger is revealed to have already made
a deal with prometheus
but tarkinus doesn't survive to regret
his choice as he's killed by malcolm
merlin
who willingly sacrifices himself by
detonating a landmine when harkness
approaches
joy courtney brought captain boomerang
to life on the big screen in 2016
suicide squad
courtney's portrayal of digger harkness
is a source of much of the humor in the
action-packed movie
and it's clear courtney and the
filmmakers drew heavily from the source
material
still there are some significant
differences between the comic book and
movie versions of the character
like the captain boomerang of the comics
digger starts his criminal career as a
flash villain
ezra miller cameos as a scarlet
speedster capturing digger in a
flashback
and just like the source material
courtney's version of digger can't stand
amanda waller
the film even adapts digger's
manipulation of slipknot into
unintentionally killing himself
from suicide squad number nine sorry
that's what i do
there are important differences between
courtney's digger and the source
material however
he's much less cruel to his teammates
ultimately shows himself to be much more
of a team player and in particular comes
off as a lot tougher than the comic book
version
jai courtney subsequently reprised her
role of captain boomerang for the 2021
movie the suicide squad
making him one of just three members of
the original team to return for the
sequel
whether digger harkness has a future in
the dc universe beyond this movie
however
is yet to be seen check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell
so you don't miss a single one